let's rock and roll let's roll i got
stuff to talk about i got i got stuff to
talk about you got stuff to talk about
yeah i do chapelle chappelle lacey how
are we doing yeah are we recording
we're rolling did you get a picture of
brian already yeah
what i do is i my my girl looked at me
and she said you need i wake up i like
to wake up in the middle of the night
and yeah and and not sleep and then i
like to do that i like to fret
because um i suffer from all kinds of
issues
you've just been thinking yeah i'd be
thinking you'd be thinking
and so what i do is i'll she'll see me
upstairs on my uh like you know my ipad
jotting down [ __ ] comedy or whatever
it is speaking of which wise guys
tomorrow
friday saturday um and then she goes
take a xanax and i'm like no no whatever
i'm going through i want to feel yeah
you want to go
i agree with that i'm that same way i'm
like i don't want to fix this this is
happening for a reason and i'm do and
i'm moving the way i'm moving because
i'm supposed to be doing this right now
it's like whenever like there's times
where i'll go to bed like late
like i'll go to bed and like if i go to
bed like one i'll still wake up at like
6 30 right and i go i'm supposed to
mm-hmm and i'm not trying to do this
like motivational because it's honest
because it's honest i go oh i'm supposed
to be up at 6 30.
get up and do something yes that's how i
feel and i think that's what you're
feeling correct yes it is and also what
i try to do now is i try to um instead
of saying i'm fine i go i like to do
this i like to
feel everything i'm going through and
i'm definitely not fine in fact i'm a
[ __ ] wreck yeah and i don't like
admitting that sometimes but um
yeah and then i just i i go deep into it
yeah and not not to other people because
that's exhausting is it because is it
because of that is it because of the
discoveries like or like or
what you'll find
because i think a lot of times i think a
lot of times when you lean into it
you're going to find something you find
something because you don't know at the
start it's kind of chaotic in the brain
yeah
but then look in the shadows you and
then all of a sudden you just find
something you're like there it is how
are you feeling yeah look at so let's
get tell us what you tell us some stuff
because i know you're you made some
choices i did make some choices yeah um
this is crazy to announce
it's hard to announce yeah but uh
i've decided to leave
the show the fi the firefighter and the
kids to constitute no eldest world no
bad blood no nothing we love you this
show is well you're going to be right
down the hill i'll be right over you'll
be in the same literally in the same
same room in the same room but yes uh
you know
i just want to say that you know i've
just
i don't know i i talked
i felt this for a while you know and
since i've been doing
chappelle's world and i'm like and i
feel bad when i come here
and
i'll be thinking about chappelle's world
yeah like my brain is on but that's the
truth on that yeah and yeah
you you i i feel like i was brent and i
were talking about how proud we were of
you because first of all i'm indebted to
you forever because you stepped up and
you saved the show yeah yeah and when
when uh everything was um
[ __ ] up
and so um
you know i think you are a man who's 35
years old who wants to do his own thing
and you're not third wheel you're not
third yeah you're not a third wheel guy
and you're certainly not a bit player
and you're not
you know but brennan and i built this
thing over 10 years
you stepped in and you [ __ ] filled
big shoes and did an amazing job yeah
and then you kind of went you know i
don't want to do this anymore i want to
do my own yeah and i feel bad when i
when i'm a part of something or doing
something
that i don't have the um
it's no disrespect to the to the show or
whatever you know it's when i don't have
a passion for something and i'm just
thinking about this other thing over
here
and tear credits it's yeah and because
if anything i always want to deliver my
best to
whatever it is that i'm doing right now
and
like even like like my my reps they'll
send me
like auditions and i go i i go i know
you want me to audition for this but i
can but reading this and i've thoroughly
read through it
i won't i wouldn't do that yeah i
wouldn't do that and and and i'm not
afraid to say no it's really because i'm
like i'm like
you know sometimes they'll be like you
know what what's the deal with that i go
i won't deliver my best with doing
something that i don't connect with
right you know or don't don't like now
i'm not saying i don't like this show no
i'm not saying that no no no i don't
know like but like there's just no it's
i think as a creative person you're
right
yes and you know especially like
you know when i sit back and look at
you know you guys i'm like man they've
built this chemistry
together over a decade and they've had
this thing in this vibe
and no i didn't it's not like a third
wheel thing it's just like i admire it
from like where i'm sitting when i you
know when when i'm sitting right here
and watching you guys
flow
and
it's like man
you know it just hit me i'm like man
i want to i want to i want to do that
i'm like they have this thing going on
right here right now
that's
their thing that they've created that
you guys have built you know and
not i'm not discrediting myself when i
say this
but i didn't build this
you know i came in at a time of like
you know when
two friends were in a time of need yeah
you know and and you guys have helped me
out tremendously so it's like
you know yeah i mean you know well i i
gotta say you know i appreciate all that
and and uh i know you're gonna crush it
as i told you the day i met you remember
i told you to come to l.a yeah yes i saw
something in you right yeah and i'm
never wrong about those things ever and
uh i i when i immediately came up to me
right when i got off the stage yeah you
said what are you doing here i'm because
i you say what you said why are you
because you still i'm the best in
where's my camera
because i'm the best in the [ __ ]
world
at spotting
talent and someone who's special i'm the
i'm the best i'm going to leave it
leading
to it gold medal like there's nobody in
my area code if i wanted to be an agent
i would have been the greatest who's at
the top podium
and everybody else is a distant second
there's nobody in my
area code do you hear me yeah good so i
don't know if you guys know this story
so
i was working at a hotel
and um i had met you prior but i was
working at hotel and you came to do
because you i met you guys when you guys
were doing fighter and a kid on the road
but then you came back
to headline
uh stand up live by yourself
and um you were staying at the hotel i
worked at and then you were like hey
won't you come by tonight man and you
know uh i'll put you up you know i'll
give you a guest spot
and um
this is when you had stevie blue eyes
uh another one another one who i stevie
blue eyes is another guy who
i think could have been he just has his
own thing it's he's just his own special
yeah
he's a very special guy like he's a very
smart guy and he he's just got his own
thing going on but stevie
um is another guy who i was astonished
at how good he was so quickly so quick
astonishing he's so smart and such a
good writer so if he wanted to he could
be he could have been bill burr or
something but that's not his thing and
it's okay and that's fine that's the
other thing i i you can't want for
people he has his own
magic and he's going to find his own way
but um i liked you right away because
you don't have any
i just was always impressed with how
and i hope you hold on to this chappelle
i hope you hold on to this what is it
you don't have a big ego man you you you
are very humble and and don't ask why
and it doesn't matter
don't as you get more successful lose
that don't get prideful don't even get
protective over what you've worked on
and what just be exactly the way you are
and you will never lose don't let people
step on you what you want what i think
it is brian and you know cause i journal
so [ __ ] much
but um
i like being a person
you know what i mean i don't know if
that makes any sense yeah what i just
said it does but
i like to be a person yeah you know like
you you've been in this industry for a
minute i think you'll go around you want
another way of saying that is that you
you like not feeling better than your
audience
yeah better than everybody else exactly
yeah because i because i mean i know
where i come from
i know what i've went through and i'm
like man that's
that's just you know that's some regular
you know that's hey people go through
some [ __ ] [ __ ] but but
but what i'm i guess i'm trying to you
know say is
you know like i said you've been in this
industry for a minute
you've seen people where they've made
this thing their sole identity
where like and it's like but you got to
live a life
yeah you know what i mean some people
well you know
because you become a [ __ ] alien
yeah you know you watch people that are
just so out of touch dude i've done
movies with you where have been actors
since they were in their teens and now
they're 60. and they don't know how to
live a life
and it's fun it's uh
to go off the thing that uh
you'll see some people
of hide celebrity caliber
and they'll say things online and you'll
see them say something and you go you're
so out of touch
with
humans yeah in general yeah to where it
was like why would you say that yeah and
not not to just sit here and punch him
in the face but when judd avatar was
like
chris rock
will smith you could have killed chris
rock yeah with that slap yeah and i'm
like yeah
well shut up
and and i'm not trying to sit here like
like i said i don't try to no i i am oh
you all i am i'll let you do it
because that's a classic exam there are
a couple things going on there one is
one is that when you have been he's
talented judd apatow is
i know a guy who knew him before he was
anybody and said that i heard like that
motherfucker's gonna be running he's
gonna be running this town
john apatow is too he's just undeniable
i i think that guy can make he's made
some of the best [ __ ] movies
i've ever seen oh like oh dude you know
i know that there are great movies out
there but i'm just talking about for
what what
yeah like those movies are amazing
they're hilarious they're moving they're
real stories real story everything that
he does and even the people he found
that he that he brought together he
might be better than me at spotting
talent with my camera where's what's
right
uh you know so i'm a huge admirer of the
guy i really am but
but he also was he embraced part of his
talent was embracing
the kind of guy he is which is a very
sensitive
uh
uh
yeah a very sensitive
uh
non-athletic yeah non-alpha
non-bro-y which is fine of course it is
there are a lot of guys like that but
but
make no mistake make no mistake it's
awesome that he captured that world of
guys the anti-hero the anti-hero yes the
anti-the
anti-romantic comedy you know this sort
of guy who uh never gets laid um because
he's got the the body of you know his
the consistency of like sort of warm
cheese
but
there's a big heart there and he's
really open and he's very vulnerable and
so 100
um
and
we love those characters
everybody everybody really like he he
create he's created characters that
everyone can root for yes but when
you've never
done a sport i'm sorry i don't care when
you've never been punched in the face
when you've never actually when you're
not friends with other guys that are
rough yeah when you don't hustle with a
guy like matt matrione or brendan or
just you haven't done jiu jitsu or you
like like when you you know even
cheerleading people make fun of you but
that's a lot of [ __ ] physicality
jumping in the air yeah yeah do a
grabbing people following injuries
if you're not like that and you see a
slap
you're like oh my god i could have
killed him yeah and that's a classic
example of being way too rich way too
way too out of touch and it's impossible
to avoid i don't blame him for it all
right let's take a little break uh first
of all you can see me this weekend at
wise guys
in las vegas and then next weekend i'm
at the stress factory in new jersey and
i got comedy loft after that can't stop
won't stop in washington dc get your
tickets at brian.com or uh
ffa
f-a-t-k-z dot com yeah where are you
gonna be
may 6-7 there's a new comedy club in san
diego
called mike drop comedy club i'll be
there and then i'll be doing a
one-nighter in the hometown uh stand up
live may 12th and then uh
in the summertime i'll be in rhode
island at the comedy connection june
24th and 25th i was at my house my
brother-in-law was uh
sweating and i hear music and i hear
somebody talking to him like he must be
in a class yeah and the guy is doing
he's boxing
but he's boxing he rides at peloton he
has a peloton bike yeah and he's
obsessed with it as a lot of people are
um
yeah they've got but peloton has new
classes and new music and you you can
they always change it up and you have
different instructors that you can get
involved with but now they have boxing
they're stepping in the ring they've got
you don't need gloves uh but it's a fast
furious fun workout they got peloton
structures in the corner there's nothing
like boxing it's a guy who boxes there's
nothing in better shape forget it um and
it doesn't matter if you've ever boxed
box before you will sweat your ass off
he was dripping you got they teach you
footwork form fun combos it's
unbelievable they have this new artist
series with these different music
collections yeah yep you don't want to
hear the same song no no you want to mix
it up especially if you're working out
correct yeah you want and a single they
got all different you want one guy for
an entire class you want all different
kind of artists
um they got everything from pop rock
hip-hop edm and then they got more daily
workout varieties they're always upping
their game you got 30-minute workouts
15-minute workouts 20-minute workouts
for cardio whatever it might be total
body workouts that's so go to one
peloton
oh
yep you want me to do it yeah visit
onepeloton.com to learn more that's
o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n.com
guys look i'm ridiculously shredded yeah
and uh and a lot of people are like
brian why do you look like somebody
stretched human skin over a cheetah well
i'm not on i'm not i'm not in ketosis
but i do i do try to be as keto as i can
a lot of times if i've eaten too many
carbs but now if you probably fat one of
the fastest ways to lose weight is to go
keto the keto diet and uh i know
brendan's always trying to work on that
so you can get into ketosis they've got
a company called real ketones
and it's basically a wellness technology
okay so what you can do is you the
the idea behind keto is to produce
ketones which happen naturally in the
liver and it gives you more energy it
burns fat increases focus makes you feel
great so you don't i guess it like
controls your insulin yeah so that your
body you never get you don't get that
brain fog or anything and you're running
more on fatty acids not on glucose which
is sugar your energy is there yeah but
it's really hard to do it with just diet
but real ketones d db
bhb it's identical to what your body
naturally makes so within one hour
you're in ketosis okay and that's
verifiable with any ketone monitor so
it's it's amazing it's a new technology
health technology basically so whatever
your goals are you whether you want
energy you want weight loss on on any
diet hydration ketosis whether you're
keto or not real ketones at bhp
is if it's part of your daily routine um
i know from brennan it is on it it's
unbelievable so um and where do you get
it
well
you go to real ketones i'm gonna spend
i'm gonna spell ketones real
k-e-t-o-n-e-s so it's one word real
ketones dot com use promo code shob for
10 off
um and if you don't love this product
they will give you your money back and
don't just don't just try to get a
refund enjoy the product yep make sure
you enjoy the product yep if you enjoy
realketones.com
use promo code shob for 10 off you ever
use on it
i haven't but i i i've been looking at
their products and
let's go ahead and lay it on me listen
right now i'm listening there are a
couple things i promise you work i know
this for a fact one is if you feel like
you're getting sick the virotec immune
uh instant or virotec immune or
shroom tech immune yeah there are they
they
they have these
different kinds of mushrooms and they
they literally do this inside in labs
basically from what i understand but
that stuff really does work to boost
your immune system
i use the shroom tech sport you know the
uh which because
again i know this for a fact it actually
works it actually
basically gives you more energy somehow
it brings atp to the to the cells i have
no idea how it works all i know is i'm
more flexible i can keep going it's
[ __ ] crazy yeah it's a shroom texture
by the way it's scientifically proven
this isn't like a point of view they got
the best creatine they got the best
another supplement that is that i have
talked to so many scientists they
there is no doubt the creatine works so
the one thing i like about on it and
they've been a sponsor for 10 years or
whatever as long as they've been around
is that the owners
would always use their own products and
i know the owners very well and i
started using their own products because
i saw how they were made and i saw how
insane they were and i remember the
first time the first time we talked to
the owners how do you want us to talk
about on it they said just be honest
use the products
and be honest
and that to me said okay these guys are
behind their product yeah vitamin d
spray they have any nutrient you want if
you want the best supplements on planet
earth it's on it dot com slash fighter
10 off
get optimized blame them for it you made
me realize something too like what's
with this thing would stand up
i was in springfield missouri yep not
too many people toured through
springfield
blue room comedy club yeah and
i to this day i i
you know i'll probably hold on to
springfield missouri forever because
they taught me something
that you had mentioned before and i
really felt it when i was there
is the level of appreciation
these are folks that are
they work on like farms
you know construction they do these
these jobs
that they're like with their hands they
touch the world their hands and they
have to adjust at the price of pain yeah
that's the wrong way to do it exactly
and
i think a lot of times
you know
within our world
we think our world is the world yeah but
to those people
i'm like their world is
this labor
this thing with that they do every day
where they they have to get up every
morning and make sure they milk the cows
or whatever they got to do whatever
whatever it is there's just there's
something about it and to be to have
those people in the audience
listening to you
and laughing at the things that you do
and and just enjoy it like
there's something i i really
like i'm proud of myself for doing is i
walked around their city i learned
anything and everything i could within
those three days
of being out there in that city and i
talked about it on stage from such a
genuine outsider a loved perspective
yeah and they erupt
because they because they they're like
oh this dude
really
cared to know about us yeah
and and i feel like that's what
continues that
type of
human connection i did that in florida i
was like and i get an uber and the guy's
got a mask and uh so
where were you yeah i was at the sonic
theater which is the amazing gig
actually yeah they'll sell out every
[ __ ] show oh well every show best
food in the world
the sonic theater okay they know how to
run that place so if you do a wednesday
you're selling out thursday you're
selling out friday you're selling out
saturdays oh it's just that spot that's
it's that spot okay it's [ __ ] awesome
and it's the best food
it's the best food in southern florida
yes and i'm not joking the sonic theater
in port charlotte in the middle of
nowhere yeah i said it
and right outside that [ __ ] theater
right outside there's a moat there's a
moat a boat you go out there it looks
like it looks like it's basically a it
looks like a um it literally looks like
a pond
like okay so you know on the side of the
road where you got the highway then you
got a [ __ ] hill and then you got like
an area like it looks like it just
rained and that area had some water in
it okay it looks like some water
so kevin mack who features for me comes
down and he goes six five kevin yeah and
he looks down he goes ah i go alligators
everywhere joking around and he goes nah
no alligator is there because it's just
a it's just a it's kind of a its own
little contained area it's as big as
this this this [ __ ]
place not this room but this of the
studio yeah
so um the guy the owner eric of the
masonic theater goes yeah
the problem is
you're wrong because
a year ago a homeless guy
or a drug guy got into that pond to wash
himself and a 10-foot alligator took off
his arm and one of his balls
and yeah tried to kill him roll took his
arm off so the guy was able to get away
so he didn't die
and they had to airlift him out of this
parking lot
now that's now that's hold on
watch this that's right outside yeah the
[ __ ] door that's like well i'm gonna
i'm gonna watch this ready i'm gonna
this is how this is how far away the
alligator is ready yeah i'm walking out
the door i'm taking one step two steps
three steps four steps five steps six
steps seven steps eight steps nine steps
and i'm in the water yeah yeah that's
how far away the alligators [ __ ]
dinosaurs
[ __ ] dinosaur right there i don't
know why what we were talking about
listen when you start going off
crocodiles or alligators
yeah so i'm in florida
i'm all over the place thank you cause i
was lost in the alligator story i think
dallas do balls got taken off that's a
better story but i said to him
the same thing with local like coming up
with a local thing to say and i know i
got an uber the guy had a mask i was
sorry we're in florida i don't know if
you guys know there was a pandemic
and they [ __ ] just went crazy crazy
right yeah yeah because it's because
they they know
they know their area they know what
they're in and do you know how much they
pri springfield missouri
prides themselves
on their bass pro shop because their
bass pro shop is three levels and it has
an aquarium and they
a
they ride or die for that damn
but it's but it's but it's just to us
like
it's such a simplistic thing but to them
this is like no it's not simply not
simplistic as much as uh you know what
i'm trying to say the the
new york the the elite of new york and
the hollywood
mindset all dumb as [ __ ] by the way dumb
as [ __ ] but the hollywood mindset
i've been in this business for 25 27 30
years there's
nobody will uh will surprise you in
their in their
lack of
intellectual vigor
than actors
and other people in hollywood trust me
it's it's as far as being like
oh they think they're smarter than
america it's so [ __ ] great it's
hilarious but they're they're so
condescending but like
one of the things about that that if you
were to go to springfield talk about
gender neutral bathrooms tell me how it
goes
talk about how important
gender politics is to people in
springfield or anywhere in this country
i've been following this really closely
because
you know
the new york times this is the most
famous [ __ ] magazine of all time
three years ago two years ago ran 81
articles on
gender neutral bathrooms and how
important
gender neutral bathrooms are for the
0.01 of people who have gender dysphoria
uh that's what they were doing and so so
so it's it's really interesting because
what what you're seeing with disney and
you're seeing with netflix and you're
seeing with all these companies is that
their
their
agenda
their
what they're putting emphasis on
which is all this sort of like we have
to worry about marginalized people
they're victims black people are victims
uh queer people are victims or whatever
trans or victims like
when you do that most of america goes
hey dude i don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about all i know is i got
i i got my i gotta get my kids to school
and i have a job and i just want i what
are taxes and how much money do i have
in the bank yeah i don't know what the
[ __ ] you're talking about yeah and oh
your
your movies and your stories that you're
you're shoehorning in all this yeah all
this like and that doesn't mean people
aren't in insincere to to people that
are
you know victims of but the people doing
this that makes sense yes but the people
doing it
are not people who live in the real
world they don't know actually how those
people that they are speaking up for
are that those they're not actually
doing that they're not actually trying
to do anything they're trying to get
power
and they've never lived in the real
world i'm going to make a distinction
that douglas murray did he was just on
rogan okay
most of us in life are trying to
construct a life
we're trying to build the life it's
[ __ ] hard you're trying to make money
so hard you're trying to have you're
trying to make a name for yourself build
your brand have a career and it's full
time my first night in missouri that
thursday night
bro
i
i had the time of my life still all the
way through
that 50 minutes of being on stage
talking to those people because right i
was like hey this room seats 200 people
yeah and there's 20 people in this yeah
right now and by the way it's the real
deal you got to keep it going you got to
keep it going and then you got kids and
then you got you got a relationship so
all of us out there are we're all white
knuckling it like all of us like i know
really wealthy people and every one of
them will tell you this it's so funny
they go well everybody has to work
because every don't how much money you
have to make 10 million dollars you
you'll go through that in two years dude
i mean it depends on your lifestyle
everybody has to work and everybody has
to hustle there are very few people that
don't have to hustle and even they will
go crazy if they don't like everybody
has to hustle do you think it's do you
think for comedians
because comedy
isn't so
forgiving at times yeah because hey
there's times we'll go up annihilate
right yeah annihilate a set
there's another then that next night
happens and there's one of those shows
where it's just hey bro it never gets
[ __ ] easy
some people would say i'm a pretty good
punches you in the soul too yeah yeah
but then you got to write a whole new
act i'm going to shoot this [ __ ]
special yeah and then i got i'm throwing
it all away gots to start from scratch
gots to start it makes it makes you
question
when that one night
is an off night it makes you question
like
yeah am i am i funny yeah
yeah it makes you really and you should
because yeah but that's the beauty of it
right it's the beauty of comedy
it's not so forgiving so it makes you go
it makes you work in a way to where it's
like oh [ __ ] i'm i'm not as funny as i
thought it was right oh it's funny out
when i did this joke in l.a yeah but
doing it springfield missouri oh
do i by the way i'm
i'm sorry about my toes my toe holds
do i look
do my my friends are making me by the
way i sit now because i'm i'm super zen
but also
also they're just jealous because they
can't sit like that because i'm jealous
i can't stop you you can't sit like that
you can't cross your thighs
ryan look at my legs bro you got some
tight heads
you can't do this though bro
come on
i can get one leg up back straight you
can't do this no no dude not on this try
it
watch
try it bro
there you go bring that [ __ ] leg up
is it tight in your little hippie
whippies
that's fine
look at that all right this is how we're
going to sit your shoe your shoes belong
on somebody in
in a kung fu movie
she just belong on the beach
we need this to say yes um
you know with with
leaving and you know moving on
i am very appreciative of this whole
experience
you know being part of a
you know a podcast that you know that
many people you know love and you i mean
we want to do people in space let me
tell you like
when i um
i was in austin texas this dude
ran up to me he's like oh my gosh spell
ac i watch 500 kid i'm a ups driver
that's what i do when i when i'm driving
you know for ups and downs and just to
hear that it's such a cool thing
it's a cool thing
that
you know
this kid from mesa arizona
a person's day
just because you know i
come in here come here and shoot the
[ __ ] yeah did they tell you did they
tell you that you're tolerant person
because they say that to me no they
don't say that
they uh know what do people say to me
chin please get more like they say they
don't know they say i'm not
as tall as i
thought get more light on my [ __ ]
house change it multiple times so many
lights
brian first of all here's the thing that
camera is not or what the way this looks
on this screen is not how it looks yeah
on the
on youtube on youtube oh okay i look
good on youtube
on youtube you're killing loving cactus
but just don't go off that damn screen
right there all right man i don't know
why you keep doing that because i have
to because it's i see it sometimes in my
whole day all the energy leaves my body
all the energy and the humor leaves my
body i go because i'm dying
what you do is you'll talk to me and
then you'll go
yeah yeah
you look at that goddamn script
this is a weird thing i was feeding my
baby my three-month-old and the kid was
like
because
he's breastfed yeah he's good he's
breastfed but but sometimes you give him
a bottle the doctor wants to give him a
bottle twice a day just because it puts
more weight on him but he's fat as [ __ ]
he just keeps growing and like i was
feeling the baby tug his life force i'm
holding this [ __ ] growing
vibrating creature that i'm responsible
for
until i die
until i die and he's sucking the bottle
like
and it was like literally like
it was like i
just by that i was like holy [ __ ]
this is a life force that i have to keep
feeding like and
there's it was it was i got exhausted i
was like i gotta do this [ __ ] until he's
at least 18. and let's be honest 18
you're a complete idiot anyway yeah
really until he's 30. so i'll be fine if
we could just keep this podcast going
for another 30 years i'd appreciate it
yeah he'd be going for brian and his
baby for brian for brian and cody i
won't have uh invisalign but i will have
dentures
although yeah so you got seven more
trays dude i had dinner and i got who
knows yeah less less yes yes seven more
i had dinner
i had six more i have six
i had dinner with a nano
a nano scientist do you know what that
is like i think he does he works on
nanobots which are like
which are like uh
computers the size robots and computers
the size of a red blood cell something
you can't even see
like atoms they push atoms around so
what these things can blow people up oh
no dude it's the it's the future of
medicine it's the future of medicine
they have so they have they can cure
diseases now like diseases like sickle
cell anemia
uh all kinds of [ __ ] that was incurable
right now they have the
capability not only to cure diseases but
using gene editing
they can take you in vitro as a baby
okay before you're even born and if you
have certain diseases that would ruin
your whole life they can detect that
already not only that not only that they
can also and they're doing it in china
even though it's a little bit unethical
in china apparently they are also like
if you're born
if you're going to be short or you're
going to be you're not you don't have a
lot of fast twitch muscle or whatever it
is
they're getting to a point where they
can turn you into a superhuman you ready
for this [ __ ] what do you mean
you have a white if two white people
are
have a baby like meatball
excuse me birth to a black child if you
would want no you can give birth to a
six foot four person no you couldn't if
you're really short you could that's
what gene editing is that's what gene
editing no they're not yeah they are and
so right now white people can have a
black baby that that like like like a
two great danes can give birth to a
chihuahua like a baby like you can [ __ ]
with jeans in vitro now now it's not
quite where it it's it's still very
dangerous
because you can [ __ ] things up but
that is being done somewhere in the
world and not only that
you can cure diseases that you could
never cure before like like in 10 years
the cancers we're worried about they're
already curing the problem is
that sometimes one dose which will cure
you one dose costs 2 million dollars how
about that two million dollars
so that's why they can't do it but that
price is going to come down so in 10
years
you guys are young you guys are in your
20s
there is a very good chance that you
will not have to worry about cancer the
way you don't have to worry about aids
like my generation age is a death
sentence now you get aids and they
desire something else oh bro
bro you died i saw it with my own eyes
slowly and you died painfully and with
no dignity you starved to death you got
the worst you your body had no immunity
so you would get crazy diseases i saw it
wait back to this uh
uh two white parents have a black baby
crisper cast nine is that what they call
it yeah look just put in put that in you
know
it's [ __ ] crazy whisper invented by a
woman uh and a man like a you know but
it's like it's changing everything
it's hard to explain i'm a doctor so i
don't want to talk about it i'm a
scientist and i i don't
you know
what about
it
i want to ask you a question but i
imagine it's going to be so stupid look
it enables geneticists and medical
researchers to edit parts of the genome
to by removing adding or altering
sections of the dna sequence
it's [ __ ] crazy but i don't
understand
where are they getting
this egg for the black baby
are they getting it from someone else
there they get it from me
um yes you can put genes into
you can clip out a gene sequence from
dna and alternate and [ __ ] put in
another gene sequence
when i hear about this [ __ ] i go oh we
must be just really sophisticated
computers
like somebody made us
like you know computers are binomial
they they work on two numbers zeros and
ones or whatever the [ __ ] it is
they there's a theory that human beings
are essentially just a very
sophisticated machine which we are a
computer that might work on five numbers
so you get into the [ __ ] and it's like
like so
we as we as we learn how to bio-hack our
body yeah whatever you can imagine is
going to happen whatever your
imagination is to the point where we're
gonna this is so [ __ ] nuts because of
gene editing
it is absolutely
feasible
in 50 years 20 years i don't know
right now i don't know where they can
they can splice your genetic
material with
a lions but but initially
and i can finally be the manther i've
always wanted to be you want to be a man
that's what you want i don't know why
would you want that i'm just telling you
that i like being a human i'm just
telling you that whatever is going on
there there are people who are probably
working on super soldiers on working on
going so far beyond our biology but
that's
here's where that becomes scary people
that love power
of course
technology it's frankenstein what would
you remember you know frankenstein the
book marriage of it the idea was that
technology is going to
alienate our us from ourselves that we
we will create a monster we can't
control although it is beautiful how
smart how smart we have gotten as humans
unlimited potential yeah unlimited which
is amazing yeah yeah but the question is
but sometimes what do you do if you're
scared what do you do with that if i
tell you so if i okay so i say to you
you can live 300 years that's a problem
it's a problem everybody wants it but
yeah i don't know do you really want it
well here's what i really want to live
300 i would dedicate i would dedicate um
i would dedicate my life to mastering
something like say music
boxing you know music combat
[Music]
uh
those are the three things and and and
and and or writing and then i don't know
i would i would i would dedicate myself
to
certain skill sets here's the other
problem though here's the other problem
what if you can download a skill set
what if i can download in your brain
ala the matrix
how to how to operate a helicopter how
to have a black belt in jiu jitsu how to
play the guitar really well what if
there's packages you can buy what do we
listen now now we have a big problem
because what the [ __ ] do i find meaning
when when are we going to when are we
going to start to fly
well we already can fly
in a plane yeah but you don't want to
fly is [ __ ] overrated
how do you know you never because what
happened
it's overrated when you've never done it
if you know anything about the plane if
you know anything about orienthology
ever anybody anybody what's orienthology
anybody anybody anybody
hey hey you guys need to start reading i
need everybody in this [ __ ] woman to
start reading the level of education
here
is not acceptable
i know but i need you right you're such
a teacher right now i need you guys to
god i just need it
i need some reading yeah i graduated
high school and that's it i know guys
but
no no oranthouse oh needs you guys it's
so important george i really like i want
will you type it in to be a little bit
interested in the
orthology
yeah if you do orthology or info or
anthology yeah right okay it's the
branches obviously the concerns the
methodology methodological study and
consequent knowledge of birds and all
that relates to them so in other words
it's all things bird you love birds
don't you i don't know
not really actually i really don't but
my i had to throw away all my stand up
on birds like i wrote a whole [ __ ] i
wrote an hour i know
my girl my girl was saying she was like
i was killing rooms i was crushing burn
material dude 40 minutes of [ __ ] bird
material i was the premier bird humorist
in the country in the world crushing
with birds and my girl was like and i go
on throwing it all out and she goes are
you out of your mind do you see what
you're doing in the room so i go i don't
care it doesn't feel right right that's
so that's it doesn't feel right that's
right my special has nothing it has very
little bird in it
very little or anthology what are the
things oh wait
anyways the reasons are flying
the reason you don't want to fly is if
you know anything about orienthology
you'd be flying and you'd have [ __ ]
eagles crows swallows hitting you in the
[ __ ] head because you're in their air
space and they're super territorial you
see how huge i am bro i know my big ass
was flying in the air you think i'm
worried about a punk ass eagle maybe but
they'd be buzzing your [ __ ] head and
hitting you right in the [ __ ] eye oh
and i can't fly
well you can [ __ ] throw a smile now
you're punching a left hook now you're
punching birds for no reason and i know
that's not unpatriotic i mean goddamn
somebody catches chappelle lacy in the
air
sucking a [ __ ] swallow but i'm
allowed to fly
i'm allowed to fly you knocked a bird
out of the sky and you're a [ __ ]
just because he was being because that
bird was protecting its nest and you
right hook it right in the [ __ ] beast
if it's coming at me but i'm but uh
we're cool i'm like hey neighbor
hey neighbor
that's what i'm if we're cool nothing
but if that is that if that eagle comes
at me you on some territorial seasons
like it's a gang nah you got two crows
okay
left hook you got too close to its
[ __ ] you got too close to its [ __ ]
nest
and and
chickens hold on whatever the what they
call the baby eagle you got you got you
got distracted you got distracted yeah
and when you got distracted you got into
some power lines and now you're [ __ ]
dead and if you're gonna flap from here
to your house you're gonna be so sweaty
and gross birds be chilling on power
lines all the time well i wouldn't
recommend it
because you might hit the wrong power
how do y'all feel about flying
people can fly
who exactly hang gliding for one that's
technically a form of flying yeah wing
suits too yup and suit and
what about what the army has now have
you seen that oh the the [ __ ] jetpack
thing yes no
oh yeah it's like a like a really like
low budget version of iron man kinda in
a way really yeah yeah all the cool [ __ ]
we do in the movies why can't we make
that [ __ ] real they are
for real
they're doing like [ __ ] like with the
halo suits look at this look at this
this oh whoa
these dudes are flying over the ocean
i mean they're not thinking about using
that war are they yeah they are
hey but what is you know how dude look
at this though you think you think his
jet pack is gonna [ __ ]
stand up next to a missile i don't know
but that [ __ ] that's how you
would rescue people and stuff look at
this [ __ ]
are you kidding me right now that is
kind of crazy see if you had this
technology would you fly over the ocean
like the entire ocean what they look
like fly to europe you run out of gas
bomb yeah and then that's you think i
want to fly with the ocean
that [ __ ] gets mighty heavy and you die
fly over the 405. that's all you need
i'll fly over the 405 all day yeah but
then there are other people flying over
the 405 then you get now you get caught
up with somebody now you got road rage
or air rage now you got air rage
and then you burn somebody because your
jets got too close to them the whole
thing's a decent wait have you heard
this thing and i i don't know if i've i
don't know if i'm just talking i don't
know if i'm just talking you can't hear
music i know if you heard this thing
where there's a train from that they
want to create from l.a to vegas yeah
that gets there in two hours i love that
have you heard of that no it's super not
tripping no but that makes sense
i'd love that trip
but the problem with that is now you got
a bunch of now you got even more riff
raff why
i don't know man it just feels like
that'd be
how much roof raft do you see on the
plane
uh in first class yeah you're right i
don't know yeah i take that in a second
though
are they really trying to do it chin is
that what it says they say it could
happen oh it could happen yeah
i don't know man oh it's an auto centric
city that's true you need your car right
scroll maybe oh they oh there are
buildings scrolled in
down or up uh down
i mean there's a there's a there's a
train from london here is that picture
you know it takes you what
bro some of these trains in in uh japan
are fast as a speeding bullet can you
look up the fastest gear in the world
yeah
and they don't even run on i think they
run on magnetic a magnetic plane
look at this [ __ ] whoa japan's
l series maglev is the fastest train in
the world with a speed of 374
miles an hour
they go to the distance from new york
city to montreal in less than an hour
that would take you [ __ ] eight hours
china has half of the eight fastest
trains and the world's largest
high-speed rail network think about that
dude
this is a real deal yeah bro right now
so they already have it yeah right now
370. i wonder what it feels like to be
on that thing probably like an airplane
uh nothing you don't really feel the
speed yeah because you're moving with it
dude
how does that work though
can you see if it's actually on tracks
yeah
if there's cars that go that fast yeah
what they have cars that go that fast
300 dude on the ground
bugatti goes 300 bugatti veyron yeah
is that true mm-hmm 372 i think was that
top speed yeah
let's look that up to you people you saw
that on a cartoon no my grandfather or
not like my grandfather is huge into
cars since i've been since i was 10
years old he's paid for this rodent
track magazine subscription that like he
gets one ship to his house and he gets
mine shipped to my house really why do
they call you meatball
um
[Laughter]
says the old guy i know i like how he
was so intrigued by that that's random
miles an hour uh they call me meatball
cause i grew up in a predominantly
italian
area italian family yeah my mom makes
the best meatballs on the planet so does
my great grandmother 98 years old still
makes the best meatballs um
and uh i was just like kind of built
like a little meatball when i was
younger oh your nickname's been meatball
for oh yeah forever oh okay and uh my
brother's hockey coach like because i
was like a little my dad's guido like i
was like a little more guido back then
so he's like oh you you're like a little
meatball you built like one year just
act like one so it's just been stuck
ever since adorable oh fine
i knew that only calling you christian
that's fine
why
i don't like meatballs
[Laughter]
ryan's going to be the difficult one no
he's a girl
yeah he's a girl that that that um
nickname has a shelf life and give it to
yourself say yeah until i'm 25 and then
[ __ ] off i'm not meatballing i don't
mind it it's either it's either meat
meatball or
theo likes to call me uh hawk tendon or
meat
call me call me red iguana while you're
at it be more random
dude he's called me hawk hawk tendon who
calls you that theo
ever since theo called me hawk uh hawk
tenant my roommates my brother uh my
brother's manager they all call me uh
just be funny
yeah
i almost called you roberbino the first
time i met you yeah you always going to
what uh don't worry about it just posted
i know i tried doing that yeah
yeah the firing scene which is what's
hysterical is i literally
i've cat made a comment about it the
other day i lit out because i was
telling her i just saw the episode of
you the other days like i could have
sworn you just we're talking about it
like so so just so you know in that in
that um podcast i um i mean in that
episode in that episode right here i had
to cry i had to cry all day and they cut
it all out i had to be in tears
hysterical from all
all day long because that was the funny
of it where i got fired but they i mean
it was real like i they needed real
tears the whole thing and it was
hilarious because um they cut it all out
i was like dude i spent all this all day
crying that was the fun that was the
point of the scene it was really funny
and then nothing i know that entirely
yeah watch how young i am look at this
get the [ __ ] out and the next person
obviously juggling now get back to work
god damn that felt good
did you have actually ever seen this
scene with you crying
uh there's a if you see that episode
there's a literally a tiny section where
i'm like
i got fired you know and he's like well
you know but
um
no god
i was actually wondering this the other
day uh
was that around the same time you got
your eyelids done because like oh
because i remember like he had this
thing true when was that
let's see how old i was i was you didn't
know when he got his eyelids though the
reason i asked was because there was a
scene like where he has i got my lids
done oh yeah
like i can't cry otherwise my tears will
be permanently no i got my i got my
eyelids done two years ago that doesn't
i'm not saying that find out when that
when that episode of um
great we should do this episode season
three so
yeah maybe
entourage brian count right
yeah
that's like
early that's early 2000's yeah rubino
entrance magic monday
2006 it says i think wow
yeah 2006 wow 2006 i was 19 years old
think about that 2006.
i was i was born in 98 so you were 39.
this one says 2007. they're both on imdb
oh yeah
oh yeah so maybe it continued or yeah no
i was 39 i was i was young
39
39 that's when i joined fire on the kid
39 class kids i know dude damn i was
watching that in eight years you know
what else flies me that's crying eight
years old yeah that's me my family would
get together every week and we would sit
down and watch that show together wow
part of the reason i moved out here
listen to me people love that show i've
never seen it all of you listen to me
this is very [ __ ] important yes
teacher write out your goals
do not
feel your way through life
be very specific about what you want to
be
who you want to be
what you are going to regret not doing
when you're 90
and what you would ask for if you know
you could never be refused if you do
that and you keep doing that and you
really face it
you will learn more about yourself and
then you will
take action and become the person you
dare be
because most of us it's really scary to
think about it it's really scary to fill
out that sort of outline for yourself
who wants to do that but if you don't do
that
it won't work out
it won't
don't suffer from wishful thinking you
know when you say we'll figure it out no
you won't
no you won't because you might be 30 but
in about a year you're gonna be 55.
that's how it works you sound like robin
williams in that dead poet society movie
oh maybe but i just know that what i'm
saying
100
true it's not an opinion it's a deep
truth
please set very specific goals for
yourself
next you know he's like all right and
it's okay if it takes a long time
anybody who tells you there are three
steps to success please run the other
way it takes forever but be specific and
it's okay if it takes forever people say
people say that
there's a whole industry written around
like you know based around these three
steps to wealth these three steps to
this and that no
sorry you only learn the hard way
you only learn by doing it wrong for a
long time yeah it's like a that's kind
of like a loophole or people try um it's
okay notice what notice you ever notice
in stand-up how people try to go around
stand up and try to go they try to go
around
the like working on being funny dude and
people don't realize right you can't you
can't go around them they get good at
like you know yeah they get good at
building a name for themselves or a
brand but you gotta you gotta have the
goods bro oh you can't go around
you know people ask me from time to time
how do i get this how do i get that how
do i get you know how do i get an agent
i don't get it i go if you're asking me
that question right now
you're you're completely out of touch
with what you really i heard gary vee
garyvee you know that guy
he's got something to say that guy's a
smart guy and um
i don't know much about him but there is
a guy who
who asked him a question goes uh how do
i get to a point where i have
independent wealth and i can just be
making money while on the beach sipping
uh pina coladas and and uh gary if he
goes
is that a serious question are you being
serious yeah and he goes oh that doesn't
exist oh that's a terrible question that
that's that'll never happen and you
shouldn't that that question is a
terrible question yeah that doesn't
exist
i don't give a [ __ ] nobody's making
money by doing nothing but sipping pina
coladas you [ __ ] don't know
i mean and also that doesn't mean
anything
you get tired of sipping pina coladas on
a [ __ ] beach
and then what i know i was just with my
buddy who was visiting me from london
who has more money he's about to sell
his company more money than anybody you
know and he's been a huge success and we
were at this hotel he's got this view
and i was like it's so funny isn't it he
goes what i go that this is that you get
used to this
that this is not what the happiness is
about that only
building something or doing what you're
supposed to do getting good at something
you know what this motherfucker's gonna
do my buddy he's got he's got now too
much money right he's got all the money
and uh he said i'm going to i'm going to
go work at a charity secretly for a week
or two i'm just going to secretly show
up and volunteer and if i think it's
worth
if it's a good charity and the people
are good i'm going to secretly donate
five million dollars to that charity
he's gonna go around his whole life and
figure out a way to make the world a
better place by giving away money but
he's gonna get in there himself get his
hands dirty where's he i wonder what his
backstory is he's usually with my age
when someone has like
a
crazy backstory or anything of that
nature they tend to do things like that
and you know that the this is how you
wear this before they've like come up
they've they've come from like this very
very bottom yeah part of life and then
they've like built their came from a
middle class middle class he had uh okay
maybe even upper middle class okay his
dad built swimming pools okay um in
connecticut and he he uh
but he he didn't have to struggle but he
was always good at money yeah always a
very good athlete always very focused
and would punch you in the face in a
couple seconds tough guy this is all you
need to know about him
57 years old
couple things to think about 57 all the
money okay all the money
uh captain of industry
owns like you know some of the fastest
growing banks he owns banks
he owns banks
and when i say banks i mean plural banks
okay 57 years old he has abs
no he doesn't take steroids no he
doesn't take testosterone he's just in
that kind of shape he has abs at 57.
he stayed with me
now he could stay at any hotel he wanted
in the world he could stay he could rent
a house for he stayed with me and you
know what he did in my house he cleaned
he cleaned the house for us because he
would wake up early and then he would he
made us dinner and went and bought
i don't know wines that i drank
i drank
how much was my mortgage in wines
huh
thousands of dollars in wine but the
[ __ ] like the the [ __ ]
just did just
went and bought us all this food and
cooked it and can cook too
that's who so so the
those are the kind of successful people
i admire dude he's not well he and the
other the the huge entrepreneur how did
he find that how did he or how did he
stay in he's he's he's but he's always
been the ballsiest [ __ ] on the
planet he's an expert uh skier and an
expert almost an olympic level horseback
rider yeah um like he does eventing the
most dangerous sport in the world where
you jump over fixed jumps and people die
when i was there with him 10 years ago
when he was he was uh he was at this
professional event
a woman died i was there a woman died
her horse fell on her they helicoptered
they put her in the helicopter she
expired in the helicopter they had a
moment of silence they had a moment of
silence and that year seven people had
died sports illustrated ran an article
saying the most dangerous sport in the
world is eventing
he was one of those guys
and then he had an accident where the
horse fell on him he broke his sternum
his pelvis his femur
his crack two vertebrae he was in a coma
and in the olympic riders came to his
hospital room and because he had
sponsored a lot of them and said you
need to quit because you're making too
many mistakes and you're going to die
but that's how balls he is so he's yeah
he's he's always been the ballsiest
[ __ ] on the planet
he's also always been brutally honest
with his own shortcomings
he's also insanely creative like he he
always says i'm not creative but he has
no idea what he's talking about because
he's the kind of guy who can find a need
he can see
where
there is a need in a marketplace
and then he goes and does the impossible
my friends who are in the business like
my family who are like he's doing
something that's kind of impossible too
many people have tried it and failed he
does it over and over again okay and and
so he's just amazing at building things
i don't know how his brain works i don't
know how he does it but even when i knew
him in college he could find ways to
make money so he's he's just he's just
one of those guys he can see it one of
my buddies he's friends with a very very
famous wwe wwe star
and um
dude's wealthy he's been killing the
game
you know because of wwe
and
he
was they they were doing
i don't know if it was wrestlemania at
staples center yeah
instead of staying in a hotel he just
stayed on my homies couch
meanwhile he's about to go
do a sold out
show in the staples center yeah and
those are the people i'm always like
because
oh because it's it's about the work
because that other [ __ ] is actually a
distraction so my my buddy said my buddy
my i'm sorry to interrupt because i want
to hear that no no no no
i'm trying to i'm trying to figure out
he doesn't wear nice clothing he wears
clothing that's that's nice he looks
good he wears clothing but he's not
going to spend a fortune on great
clothing he's not even going to i went
to he took a hotel room until he had to
do some work for a conference so he took
a hotel room the last day and i walk in
the room he doesn't even have a view i
went i went i was like but you're on the
third floor there's no there's the view
of the street he goes i don't give a
[ __ ] it doesn't matter to him he'll fly
business or first class it doesn't
matter he can fly privately he can do
whatever he wants
business doesn't matter it helps like
business there's no ego
he he'll fly business because he's not
that big and he's like i i gotta bet it
doesn't matter and i don't care about
like the guy is all about utility the
guy is all about building something what
gets him excited is getting good at
something he's okay is he's he was a
phenomenal hockey player he's a really
good athlete he's one of those guys like
the way he skis he's an expert skier
he's an expert like i wouldn't go skiing
with him and he he's like
he's he's so he was so [ __ ] good at
skiing like he would go so fast and jump
he's just fearless yeah then he decides
i'm gonna become um
well then he becomes a [ __ ] 100
million dollar multi-hundred million
dollar man and and decides i'm to change
you know i'm going to i'm going to i'm
going to just
i'm going to just become a huge
entrepreneur in another country
in another country he goes to london and
he's not from london no dude he's from
connecticut
he's a [ __ ] italian guy from
connecticut yeah goes to the london
school of economics
my dad gave him his first job
he was he was 18 19. he was graduating
from college my father called the guy
and said look
don't give this guy any special
treatment i don't want i don't want that
on my head if he sucks you got to fire
him i'm just giving him a job do
whatever the guy calls him the guy calls
my dad
i don't know
three months later and he goes hey
listen my dad goes fire the kid if it's
a problem no no you don't understand you
don't understand
he's the best employee i've ever had
i've never seen anybody work harder he's
showing up yeah he's two hours he's here
two hours early and two hours late he's
he's he's changing the whole way we do
everything he was [ __ ] twenty-one
this is just like this is how he just
said he was really altered he was an
intern yeah
so
some people are just undeniable mm-hmm
and and the reason he has a lot of
respect among big entrepreneurs the
people of the the multi-billion dollar
is because he did it all on his own he's
just a true entrepreneur he didn't have
any help he didn't know anybody he
didn't have any connections he didn't
have anything he just he just went out
and just
just said i'm gonna do this yeah no
those are the stories i'm always curious
of i'm always curious of the person
that has the wealth yeah but doesn't
wear the wealth yeah if that makes sense
yeah can i ask can i add one more thing
go ahead he's also um kept his marriage
he's got a great marriage after
30 years still in love with his wife
still treats her like a queen
he's his son is a [ __ ]
phenomenal
his son right now is playing with gang
of youths that you know that group oh
yeah uh i met a son yeah that that that
kid oh wow that's louis who was here
louie is playing with gang use louis is
a drummer on such a high level plays
piano guitar which he's doing now but
his drumming is on a different [ __ ]
level wow and so he and he's got this
incredible relationship with his dad so
the man's also a family man he also has
a an older son who almost died when the
when he was 18 months and so he has
special needs now yeah but but so it's
it's been awesome
that type of separation
yeah and as i think about him this is my
friend i've known since i was 18. okay i
i was thinking about a lot this week
because he came to he stayed with me and
i was just like some people are able to
hold it together and stay humble
and stay giving
he just is like one of those guys he
just [ __ ] takes care of yeah and not
saying that people that have wealthy
when they want to spend their money
that's that's fine you could do that but
i'm always those are the people
that i'm always curious about i'm like
how how did you find
that level of uh
i don't know
being grounded i guess that's the word
that i'm looking for yeah but there's
something about it to where i'm just so
like when my buddy was telling me yeah
he goes yeah he's a big wwe star
but he was like hey mike i just can't
crash on your couch for a couple nights
one it's great in town doing the that's
important
he was like you don't want to get it
because i just asked questions do you
know why i like that it goes back to
what i've said before and i think it's
it's rogan's secret
it keeps you
it reminds you it continues to remind
you that you are not better than the
people you're performing for
you are not better i don't care how much
money you make i don't care how famous
you are yeah the minute and i really
believe this and i know this it's not i
believe it i know it and rogan knows it
too we've talked about it
um
you are not better than the people
you're performing you don't know more
about life you're not smarter you're
good at one thing that's rewarded
disproportionately
i'm really good at stand up so i make a
lot of money doing that if i can sell
tickets yeah but that's it like i was
lucky enough to be an actor so maybe
some people know me a little bit
but that means absolutely [ __ ] all in
terms of being better than somebody i
don't know more than anybody i've made
more mistakes than all you guys because
i'm older
and i
am more educated
let's get to reading
but other than that i am not if we come
back here and we don't have any ounce of
i'm not going to tell a new intelligence
or whatever
brian's gonna flip i'm just an old guy
i'm talking like a dad
come sit on my lap everybody
not you cal get in trouble
i don't need any more of that trouble oh
gosh
that's amazing
i don't know
well you want to go into current events
let's just have a [ __ ] moment of
silence oh jen what do you got
that was quick what's happening to tony
robbins ish no no no i actually wrote
down your advice too yeah good
you see what you did there well chin i
admire you very much thank you i admire
you very much generosity your [ __ ]
courage and your strength and your
consistency you're an amazing guy
as i get older i find i i i love both of
you guys i don't know you well enough
you're too young i'm not going to
compliment you but i love you
i love you
but
but you're both the fact that you both
show up every [ __ ] time here is a big
deal to me i don't know it's just you
become a huge part of the show there's
something about that
i don't know what it is that that thing
that you both have and chin man i mean
you know of course i love you but you're
so young but yes you know but you've
been consistent you're always here
you're always no matter what and you
always make it pleasant that's not that
is not to be underestimated yeah that's
a big [ __ ] deal it says a lot about
who you both are
i love you for that so all right love
you too brian i have to mention i am
doing a few more episodes because
brendan's out of town oh yeah brendan's
out of town yeah his special drops
tomorrow tomorrow april 28th at uh 9 a.m
he's doing press right now he'll be
doing press next week too yeah he's
already done the uh impulsive yeah uh
he's doing yeah chrissy d's i think
doing rogan's
he's doing quite a fragrance yeah he's
he's doing all the all the press he's
doing all the press and then we are
going to be back to doing fighter in the
kid just you and i so that'd be great
and and thank you guys for being
understanding when i called you and you
know being very uh dude we love you
supportive just i just want the best for
you i don't give a [ __ ] yeah i i say
this to everybody who's young i said
it's kevin mac now kevin mac is doing an
amazing job he's [ __ ] crushing it
this dude kevin mack he's writing on a
level dude i'm telling you um i said to
kevin i called him up he's he's writing
he is [ __ ] killing the room and he's
six five and looks like that and i said
you could be a huge star you could be a
headliner if you do this and capture a
great half hour
and put it on youtube and you look like
that
you're gonna be yeah he's gonna be the
next big thing i'm telling you right now
he's [ __ ]
um
and what was i saying though what was
that
[Laughter]
you're so yeah he's very captivating
yeah so i just listened so what
uh hold on tell everything you said you
loved us you said you loved us uh i said
thank you for being understanding oh
yeah you want the best oh yeah i said
that
god damn it
i said to kevin and i said this to malik
i said this to uh my buddy herman
i said look
the if you're opening for me if you're
my feature you should be stepping on my
face to get to the next level the point
is i don't want your loyalty i want you
to use me to get to the next level
use me i'm putting you out there i don't
need any loyalty i don't need any thanks
you're just worth the effort so now take
that as a stepping stone and get
yourself to the next level yeah that's
what i said to him so it's the same
thing so that's how i feel about this
yeah you know you you were able to get
here and and you know it's in so now
it's time to go and do your thing it's
awesome so we'll see i mean i'll just be
dead just come to my [ __ ] funeral
or just go go or go to his shows you'll
have great teeth at your funeral you'll
have great more months [ __ ] two
more two more months go to his funeral
or shows wise guys wise guys this
weekend and uh stress factory next
weekend in new jersey i can't wait new
brunswick new jersey and then i got the
comedy loft dc comedy loft
that's the weekend after that in may
you're in d.c
i love dc here it is florida again
oh [ __ ] and then i have uh west palm
beach see i knew it lord i knew it i was
just like i was talking about my special
taping my improv taping may 19th yeah
and then i got richmond virginia the
funny bone uh i'm taking no time off and
then i got omaha june 10th to 11th i'm
taking well i guess the original funny
bone isn't it
i'm working seven weekends in a row
holy [ __ ]
can't stop won't stop guys
all right what do you got jim first one
this one is for chappelle hey
the guitar this article is titled in a
way i don't know if this is true or not
but the guitar that broke up oasis is
this yes yeah they broke up yeah okay
it's going up for auction and it could
be sold for half a million dollars
you want that to your uh five thousand
dollar guitar collection chapelle
are you sad you want that
yeah that's that's my that's the dream
that's the north
eat a dick
i hate you no i mean it's awesome it's
the [ __ ] north star that's the one
that that guy touched
i'm just saying i'm excited about it
why did do they speak do they do they
still speak
no i don't think i don't think they've
spoken in a long time i mean they'll
talk [ __ ] to each other online they they
still it's so funny because i think they
live like super close to each other they
still don't talk too i think their kids
have gone to the same schools and [ __ ]
but they don't talk to each other no
that's so sad i don't think i don't
think that's so go back go down let me
see what this this ego these egomaniacs
are talking about but honestly they'll
give each other like props written like
credit where credit is due can i see
this can i see this they do they i think
they love each other
this is old this is old
why why are you why do you want me to
cry i don't know enough for voices i
don't know for them
it kind of all started to unravel if i'm
being honest when
he started his calling label she was
kind of it was right does that even mean
though chappelle like
i'm on that guy's side just so you know
i'm on noah
that
gallagher's
dude yeah who wouldn't be
because i [ __ ] saw that documentary
that i had to sit through and that other
dude who's the other [ __ ] guy
liam yeah that [ __ ] dude he's got the
biggest ego of all [ __ ] time the
biggest ego of all time so [ __ ] both
dudes
no
no no no it was like i don't want to be
advertising clothing when we're doing
music and [ __ ] liam was like you know
it's all about me i'm awesome because i
have long hair so [ __ ] that guy yeah
team no
team no man i can't believe that you
shouted that out loud liam broke up a
band and yeah true or false no they but
they [ __ ] both writing each other's
necks they both broke up the band bro
they both broke that band you're the
you're the therapist you got liam and
you got no there
who do you side bro they both have crazy
egos who do you talk to first and most
gun to your head bro don't be the older
who knows the oldest
i would talk to noel first
yeah about and you'd say and you'd say
listen it's your brother's fault your
little brother's fault you know what you
know it's you know it stems back from a
lot what from when they were kids
knowles their their dad was very abusive
i bet and i think i bet there's a lot of
damage yes and
no the uh i think noel got it worse than
liam
so there's this well this kind of yeah
and i know and i know like that feeling
personally because that [ __ ] is real
yeah like when you get it worse when one
parent gives one kid
worse treatment than the other parent or
than the other kid or whatever so i
think that's where it stems from i think
it's more than just the [ __ ] record
label or anything like that i don't
think those dudes have ever gone to
therapy
oh no
you know and talked about their [ __ ]
yeah well it's a i think it's terrible
when two brothers can't
bury a hatchet oh yeah like what are you
doing dude
what what are you what are you winning
what are you winning yeah but that's
damage that's that's just
[ __ ] pure you go
all right what's the next thanks for
showing me that i'll buy you that guitar
for half a mill
so james gunn is currently defending
chris pratt because there are a lot of
fans who are crying to have chris pratt
taken out of the guardians of the galaxy
like main character role because he goes
to a church that people are saying is
anti-lgbt
uh i don't know how true or untrue that
is but james gunn had taken to twitter
to defend chris relentlessly because
chris also stuck his neck out for james
gunn to be reinstated after he got fired
from the guardians of the galaxy
[ __ ] all of this but what does his
religious beliefs have to do with
anybody oh they're the most they're
they're the biggest pieces of [ __ ] on
the planet
i don't know i don't know this religion
i
wouldn't dig any further and i don't
know chris or whatever but but
to just sit there
there's a lot of people with [ __ ]
crazy real religious beliefs look man
but you know what hey let him have it
if he's keeping it to himself yeah
little man shout out to james gunn shout
out to james gunn who's james gunn by
the way he's the director he goes he
isn't i don't know the church he
currently goes to do you the answer is
you don't but you heard from someone who
heard from someone who heard from
someone where he goes to church they
decided yeah okay okay i believe this
terrible thing i heard online about this
celebrity yeah well well done but also
also [ __ ] those people and someone said
it's always about money my friend always
yeah it's sad you see the world down
yeah who is this ty smith who said that
who said that yeah some random person
yeah he's a dum-dum these people are
they're not even real so who cares about
them
yeah you know go [ __ ] yourself it's kind
of twitter go [ __ ] yourself all those
people go [ __ ] yourself
all right they don't matter
oh this is great
sorry bro
i know it bothers me
so you were talking about joe rogan
earlier with the uh
the douglas murray guy yeah he was
talking about how
during the height of all of his
cancellations he actually gained two
million subscribers
during americans hate cancel culture yes
absolutely and then he continues to make
fun of cnn for putting their program
into a paid subscription site when
people don't want it when it's free oh
dude did cnn nobody wanted cnn when it
was free yeah they put 300 million
dollars into cnn plus whatever [ __ ] it
was and
and guess what they had like
10 000 signups or less can i ask you
something
when do you think
because obviously they're trying to
council culture is trying to
put out some type of message
when do you think
when do you think it's right
harvey weinstein
bill cosby
when you have 80 women telling the same
story
when you have uh
you have 50 people saying this guy's a
monster to work with
that that's fine when when when it's
coming from
people who are telling the same story
and that's when you know i believe in
due process but if you have enough
evidence if you have enough people
telling the same story if you have
enough people saying
this [ __ ] guy is a problem and uh or
oh this woman or whoever look amber
heard
it
in a court of law you're starting to see
that amber heard
has some big [ __ ] personality
deficits or liabilities or disorders or
whatever you want to call it but it
looks like
everybody believes johnny depp and
nobody believes amber heard it looks
like johnny depp is awesome and amber
heard sucks
that's
that's because
everybody is going i think you took
advantage of the me too movement
to gain some notoriety for yourself and
you destroyed somebody's life and as
johnny depp said he lost nothing short
of everything and she was fine with that
because it just upped her profile and
she did great but what happens is
all of a sudden in a court of law we're
all going hold on here oh it looks like
there are two sides to this and it looks
like there might be something called
toxic femininity as well and she's an
example of it if i'm if in my humble
opinion yeah and it's just my opinion
yeah but i have a little emotional
investment in this if you can imagine
so
it seems to me that you know
that's where i think
that's that's like everything there's a
good side and a bad side to things in
every revolution eats its young
so when you have a revolution when you
have like the metoo revolution or black
lives matter the pendulum always swings
all the way over but then it comes back
to the middle because you can never live
all the way over there yeah it it you
cannot help but to have the pendulum
come right back to the middle and you
start to see that some things work some
things don't okay
um
so
i think that's the most important
takeaway yeah is to realize that when
you have in the beginning of canceled
culture when you have these kinds of
things and somebody can no longer earn a
living
that's not good on hearsay if you told
an inappropriate joke that's sexual in
nature and you get fired from a job
after doing work
a stellar work with a sterling
reputation for 50 [ __ ] years
something's wrong here
something is very wrong everything is
just becoming a situation this is bad
this is bad this is bad this is yeah
because disney
fired johnny depp with no due process
and this is what corporations do they
err on the side of caution because
they're there they go oh let's just
believe this person because right now
it's fashionable to believe in this
person because right now the mob
will make us do that and if we don't
we'll lose our [ __ ] i might get fired
so the problem with revolutions and the
problem with with with a lack of due
process is that
you will have very good people dragged
down because other good people have no
choice but to behave corruptly because
they're scared of their own ass
it's a climate of fear it's mccarthyism
in one way or another do you know
mccarthyism no it was when there was a
in the 50s in this country if you were
considered a communist sympathizer
people are terrified of the communists
it was like a red creep the reds were
coming and so in hollywood entire groups
of people
never worked again
great directors and actors never worked
again
because they were
uh they went to a meeting that
communists were at because they wouldn't
give up names they had congress had the
the the committee on un-american
activities it was a committee led by joe
mccarthy who was a senator i believe
from wisconsin
and he dragged people up and said did
you ever did you ever go to a meeting
with communists and who were who was at
that meeting we are here to get those
names and i think david merrill who
directed high noon who was a great
director said i am not giving i am not
giving you those names i don't believe
this is this is un-american he said have
you no decency sir and he said that to
joe mccarthy and he never worked again
and he couldn't feed his kids so we've
been through this before yeah and it was
because you might be a communist or you
might be a communist sympathizer david
merrill was kicked out of those meetings
for arguing
against communists yeah and he wouldn't
give up names but you know who did elia
kazan
eli kazan was the guy who directed
marlon brando and on the waterfront and
all those movies and so when when he got
a standing ovation at the academy awards
for a lifetime achievement award you saw
people like amy madigan and nick nolte
and other really great actors sitting on
their hands they had their hands and you
can see it you can bring it up they were
just sitting there they were just
sitting there with their hands in their
hand because they didn't believe in
standing up and clapping for him because
he ruined a lot of careers through his
testimony or at least that was that was
the accusation
so
i think in that sense that's why cancer
culture is dangerous because if you are
not going to have due process you're
next [ __ ] yeah now
you can also get rid of monsters there
are monsters out there agreed and if
there's a monster out there like harvey
weinstein who's a bad bad [ __ ] person
which we all knew about yeah and i keep
a lot of
my girlfriend i keep telling you my
girlfriend who came to my defense but my
girlfriend
who was the first person to come out
against harvey weinstein she was the
first person to go to the new york times
and i remember her telling me that story
15 years ago maybe it was 20 now
i remember her telling me the story and
i remember her telling me that a lot of
other famous actors who i won't name had
the similar experience with harvey
weinstein
okay
so and i also had two friends that
worked with harvey weinstein and you
know what they said about him
they were like i just can't i've never
met anybody who lies like that he just
lies he's a liar yeah i mean he just
lies and then
he's acts like nothing happened
so you understand no no no i get it yes
bill cosby is
obviously a sick [ __ ]
criminal rapist
terrible thing that
you know and he had did he left a great
legacy according to dave chappelle if
you see the like all the money he gave
to the
different
charities but 80 women dude yeah that's
it doesn't
make up for that of course not yeah so
i'm i like every revolution
that's that's
i was one of those people i lost
everything i lost my career it won't
come back it won't
and
30 years of work
sucked
but it's the truth yeah i i have to
figure that out but
you know um that happens sometimes it
happens and all i can do is key into who
i am yeah and you know but
you know so it's it's it it hits home to
me but it should hip home to everybody
because your brother your sister your
son could be next yeah
and they will be
yeah
so
i wish i could sing a song now
well hopefully there's a lot of
songs i'm gonna show you a tick tock
that went viral and there is some songs
in here
so if you keep going
this girl made a random tick tock and go
back and go forward
so this tick tock went viral
that's where it stops go back now and
just wait
ah
so this is the tick-tock that went viral
and if you keep going people are making
duets
no matter what i do
oh baby
all right whenever you're ready take
your time okay me and you don't be
nervous
it's great
all the time i turn around brothers
gather round always looking at me up and
down looking them up
turn around
again
oh my god i love when they make videos
like that oh i love it it's so funny
they do it whenever someone like eats
[ __ ] too yeah and they just [ __ ]
people were just so quick with it
the internet is undefeated that was the
last one that's undefeated we should
probably on this note because it's
a high happy note yeah happy note yeah
that's a good note sorry for bringing
everybody down no it's time
no i asked the question i was curious
yeah chappelle we got a couple more
episodes a couple more episodes and then
uh you're going to be killed
uh wise guys counting this weekend
thursday friday saturday new brunswick
stress factory may 567 washington dc dc
comedy love come see me may 12th to the
14th brea california i got my special
taping very special guest very special
guest surprise guest may 19th get your
tickets to the bray improv west palm
beach florida improv may 27-29
briancallan.com for tickets or um t-fat
k-z for tickets yeah f-a-t f-a f-a-t
it's always trippy all right well uh and
then i'll be may 6th and may 7th uh new
comedy club in uh san diego opening
called mic drop comedy club i'll be
there then i'll be doing a one-nighter
in the hometown phoenix at stand-up live
and that's may 12th and then uh
summertime time
uh june 24th and 25th i'll be in uh
rhode island at the comedy connection so
uh thank you appreciate oh and support
my podcast if you enjoyed me here yep uh
you know would love for you to follow me
over there and just follow my journey um
you know the rest of the way chappelle's
world chappelle's world oh yeah i didn't
even say the name
chappelle's world you get it all right
is that it guys that's it
yeah your life
that's it
this is
better than a kid we're out